This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。人类出品，必属精品。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例只有2%。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。名字就是两个数字的 2。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回味往事》播客节目中。对1979年来说，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回味往事》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难一课》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难一课》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, dive into the psychology of our 20s. How are you going? How have we all been? It's been a while since I asked
大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们要深入探讨二十岁的心理学。你们最近怎么样？大家最近都过得怎么样？我好久没问过这个了
that and I'm not expecting an answer since this is kind of just me in this room right now recording. But sometimes it feels nice to just imagine you all on the other side, listening in your car or at work or at the gym, whilst you're cleaning the house. I hope you're all doing amazing and there is something great you are looking forward to or something you're especially grateful in life at the moment. This week's topic is a little bit heavy and might be rather intense for some people, perhaps very vulnerable and revealing. So I thought it would be nice to just start out with something positive to focus on
而且我并不期待回答，因为现在这房间里差不多只有我一个人在录音。但有时，想象一下你们所有人都在另一端，在车里、在工作岗位上、在健身房里，或者在打扫房子时收听，感觉真的很不错。我希望你们都过得非常棒，并且生活中有什么美好的事情让你们翘首以盼，或者有什么让你们此刻格外感恩的事。本周的主题有点沉重，对某些人来说可能相当激烈，也许非常脆弱且暴露隐私。所以我想最好先从一些积极的事情开始聚焦，
before we jump straight in because today we are going to be talking about father wounds. and the ways in which our relationship with our father within the family dynamic can lead to a lot of difficult beliefs, difficult emotions, difficult behaviors later in life. Father wounds are really complex and really difficult and they emerge from a myriad of different experiences, mainly our fathers being absent in our childhood, being emotionally or physically unavailable, consistently prioritising work over family, not taking on a positive and active role in our lives, perhaps being abusive. Anything that disrupted the dynamic or relationship between you, the child, and your father,
然后再直接切入正题，因为今天我们要讨论的是父爱创伤。以及我们在家庭动态中与父亲的关系如何在日后导致许多困难的信念、困难的情绪和困难的行为。父爱创伤非常复杂且非常艰难，它们源于无数不同的经历，主要是我们的父亲在我们的童年中缺席、在情感上或身体上无法陪伴、持续将工作置于家庭之上、没有在我们的生活中扮演积极主动的角色、甚至可能虐待我们。任何扰乱你（孩子）与父亲（照顾者）之间动态关系的事，
the caregiver, can result in this form of unresolved trauma or disconnect. Divorce, cheating, alcoholism, a few other reasons. example, remarriage, having a new younger family. These are all things that disturb or injure the connection and the attachment that we have with this important figure in our lives. And it can be really formative and impactful. People sometimes call it daddy issues. I don't love that term, especially in a clinical sense, because it's become very poppy, I guess. And I also think that it has been reduced to kind of shame women in particular for their sexuality. You know, she likes to have a lot of sex because she has daddy issues.
这种照顾者都可能导致这种形式的未解决创伤或情感断层。离婚、出轨、酗酒，还有其他一些原因。例如，再婚，组建新的年轻家庭。这些都是扰乱或损害我们与生命中这个重要人物之间的联系和依恋的事情。这可能具有高度的塑造性和影响力。人们有时称之为“恋父情结”。我不太喜欢这个词，特别是在临床意义上，因为我觉得它变得非常通俗流行。而且我也认为它被简化了，特别是用来羞辱女性的性观念。你知道，她之所以有很多性生活，是因为她有恋父情结。
It's a lot more complex than that. And I think this kind of language is quite reductive. As with anything that has to do with psychology and our mental health and our emotional state and our behaviors, the explanation is not always as simple or simplistic as we might hear on social media or as might be displayed online. And a lot of the time, our father wounds really only begin to be revealed as we grow older, especially in our early or late 20s, sometimes even later for some people, when we have left the orbit of our family, we have flown the nest. We are beginning to see what may have been normal for other people that was not the case for
这要复杂得多。而且我认为这种语言相当简化。正如任何与心理学、心理健康、情绪状态和行为有关的事物一样，其解释并不总是像我们在社交媒体上听到或网络上展示的那样简单或单一。很多时候，我们的父爱创伤真的只有在我们长大成人后才开始显露出来，尤其是在我们的二十岁初期或晚期，对某些人来说甚至更晚，当我们离开家庭的轨道，羽翼渐丰离开家巢时。我们开始看到对其他人来说可能是正常的事情，但对我们自己来说却并非如此。
ourselves. I think we are given both the gift and the curse of hindsight and the ability to compare our childhood history with our friends' experiences. And when we do that, often, if you are someone who has a father wound, a gap emerges. You begin to see that you might not just be an angry person or a sad person or a reactive person or someone who lacks confidence and trust in themselves. It's actually a lot deeper than that. And the truth is contained in our childhood memories. It's not all about your personality. You were not destined to be this individual.
我认为我们既被赋予了后见之明的礼物和诅咒，也有能力将我们的童年历史与朋友们的经历进行比较。当我们这样做时，通常如果你是一个有父爱创伤的人，就会出现一个巨大的鸿沟。你开始明白，你可能不仅仅是一个愤怒的人、悲伤的人、反应过度的人，或者是一个缺乏自信和自我信任的人。这其实要深得多。真相就蕴含在我们的童年记忆中。这并不全关乎你的性格。你并非命中注定要成为这样一个人。
There was something that emerged between you and your caregiver that has created a whole pattern, a whole flow-on effect of things that as an adult you're only now just working through. I think as we grow into our adult selves, we often become a lot more reflective and critical of our childhood experiences. We think back on the things that we had to accept or at least tolerate as children when we were dependent on our caregivers, when we were powerless and vulnerable. And now as independent people, we can be a bit more honest about it because we don't need
在你和照顾者之间出现了一些情况，从而引发了整个模式，产生了一连串的影响，作为成年人的你直到现在才刚刚理清头绪。我认为，随着我们成长为成年人，我们常常会对自己的童年经历进行更多的反思和批判。我们会回想起那些我们在依赖照顾者、无能为力且脆弱的童年时期不得不接受、或者至少不得不容忍的事情。而现在，作为独立的人，我们可以更诚实地对待它，因为我们不需要
to be kind of in a survival mode. That honesty often reveals things that we have suppressed or avoided thinking about for a long time out of a need for self-preservation. We didn't know what we know now. We were just kids who accepted the standard that was set for us. And we didn't yet have the cognitive or the mental skills to kind of rationalize our experiences and have an adult understanding of what occurred or we felt was pain. And this can be a really scary thing to unpack because we don't like to see our parents, our fathers as being fallible or even human. For so long, they have to be a really scary thing to unpack. this almost godlike status in our minds. They can do anything, say anything, they are everything.
处于某种生存模式中。这种诚实往往会暴露出我们为了自我保护的需要而压抑或避免思考了很久的事情。我们当时并不懂得现在所知道的一切。我们只是接受了为我们设定的标准的孩子。我们当时还不具备认知或心理技能来理性化我们的经历，也无法对所发生的事情或我们感到的痛苦有成年人的理解。解开这一切可能会非常可怕，因为我们不喜欢把父母、把父亲看作是会犯错的、甚至是有血有肉的人。长期以来，他们在我们心中拥有这种可怕的、近乎神明般的地位。他们可以做任何事，说任何话，他们就是一切。
So it feels strange to think that this person who we entrusted with all of our needs may have done something to harm us either knowingly or unknowingly. Unconsciously as well, we may not even realize that this is what has happened and that there are certain dysfunctional habits or patterns in our romantic relationships and our professional careers in our friendship. that all come back to our childhood. There is a lot of resentment, perhaps, that comes up later in life when your parents do get older and you suddenly realize that you have to take care of them and there are certain things that you haven't quite worked through.
所以一想到这个我们把所有需求都托付给他的人，可能做过某些有意或无意伤害我们的事，就会觉得很奇怪。在无意识中，我们甚至可能没有意识到这就是发生过的事情，并且我们的恋爱关系、职业生涯、友情中存在着某些功能失调的习惯或模式。这些其实都可以追溯到我们的童年。当父母年事已高，你突然意识到必须照顾他们，而某些事情你还没有完全想通时，日后可能会产生很多怨恨。
Or maybe you are about to become a parent you are considering having children and you're like, I don't want to repeat what I experienced. There's a sense of inadequacy because there was never a good example set for you. There is so much to be said about the impact that these wounds have. And there is a lot of misinformation. They have become this idea, this concept of father wounds has become somewhat of a buzzword. And with that, we often become detached from what is really occurring in our unconscious, subconscious, subconscious minds on a very psychological and emotional level. We aren't exactly clear on what it means to have a father wound from an attachment perspective.
或者也许你即将成为父母，你正考虑生孩子，然后你会想：我不想重蹈覆辙。你会有一种无能为力的感觉，因为从来没有人为你树立过一个好榜样。这些创伤所产生的影响有着说不完的话题。而且其中存在着大量的误解。它们已经变成了这样一种观念，父爱创伤这个概念在某种程度上已经成了一个流行词。随之而来的是，我们常常脱离了在非常心理和情感层面上，我们的无意识、潜意识中真正发生的事情。从依恋的角度来看，拥有父爱创伤到底意味着什么，我们并不十分清楚。
And we aren't exactly clear on where to go from there. How do we work through this on our own, maybe with our family, with a romantic partner? Is forgiveness the best policy? I don't think so. I think it requires more than that. There is an acknowledgement of our father wounds that at some point we're all going to have to do. We're all going to have to reflect on. And I want to talk about it today.
而且我们并不确切清楚接下来该去向何方。我们该如何独自解决这个问题，或许与我们的家人、浪漫伴侣一起？原谅是上策吗？我不这么认为。我认为这需要做更多的事情。我们都需要在某个时刻对我们的父爱创伤进行承认和反思。我们都必须对此进行反思。我今天想谈谈这个。
Starting, of course, with a theoretical premises for why these occur. So a lot of the research that father wounds are based around comes back to attachment theory. One of the most well-known, I think, concepts and doctrines in psychology. I'm sure we've all heard of it before. But for a brief refresher, attachment theory was first introduced by two psychologists, John Bolby and Mary Ainsworth, and it followed their observations of children, specifically like quite young children, infants almost. and they expose these infants to these situations in which their parents were absent or they were approached by a stranger or they were left in a strange situation
当然，首先要从这些现象发生的原因的理论前提开始。因此，父爱创伤所基于的很多研究都可以追溯到依恋理论。这是心理学中最著名、我想也是最知名的概念和信条之一。我相信我们以前都听说过。但简单复习一下，依恋理论最早由两位心理学家约翰·鲍比（John Bowlby）和玛丽·安斯沃思（Mary Ainsworth）提出，它源于他们对儿童的观察，特别是相当小的儿童，几乎是婴儿。他们将这些婴儿暴露在父母缺席、有陌生人接近或被留在陌生环境中的情境中，
and they observed their interactions and from that they came to this conclusion that the child's relationship with their caregiver would predict how they behaved in this strange situation and from their behaviors we could categorize these children into attachment styles as children we have some very core physical, emotional, mental, even social needs. And we are entirely reliant on our parents to fulfill these for us. This of course includes the need for security, the need for emotional safety and availability for comfort, for food, for love. Not every parent meets their children's needs in the same way or in the way that their
并观察他们的互动，由此他们得出结论：孩子与照顾者的关系可以预测他们在这种陌生情境下的行为，根据他们的行为，我们可以将这些孩子归纳为不同的依恋风格。作为孩子，我们有一些非常核心的身体、情感、心理甚至社交需求。而我们完全依赖父母来满足这些需求。这当然包括对安全感的需求、对情感安全和陪伴的需求、对安慰、食物、爱的需求。并非每个父母都以相同的方式或以孩子所需要的方式来满足孩子。这是生活残酷的事实。有些人不知道如何为人父母。他们不知道如何抚养孩子。而这通常具有很强的代际传递性。我们的父母、我们的父亲之所以会有那样的行为，是因为他们的父母就是那样行事的，
child requires. It is just a sad fact of life. Some people do not know how to be parents. They do not know how to provide for their children. And this is often very generational. Our parents, our fathers, behave the way that they did and that they do because of how their parents acted,
而他们的父母之所以那样，又是由于他们自己的成长经历。这可以通过育养方式代代相传，并且当我们在想要或确实拥有自己的孩子时，这种循环便会继续。孩子们所拥有的关于亲子关系的唯一模版就是失调的。我们在童年中需求是否得到满足，会影响我们在关系、育养、友情中如何与自己及他人相处，这关乎我们的自尊、独立性、处理冲突的能力等等。
who were the way that they were because of their upbringing. And that can get passed down to us through parenting styles and the cycle continues with the impact on our behaviours when we perhaps want to or do have our own children. children, the only model that we have for a parent-child relationship is dysfunctional. How our needs were met or not met in childhood affects how we relate to ourselves and others in relationships, in parenting, in friendships when it comes to our self-esteem, our independence, our ability to deal with conflict, and so much more.
现在，根据依恋理论，在支持性和陪伴型照顾者身边长大的孩子更有可能发展出安全型依恋风格。根据最近的估计，大约占我们总数的65%。相比之下，那些照顾者参与度较低的人，也就是可能带有父爱创伤的人，更有可能发展出不安全型依恋风格，例如回避型或焦虑型依恋风格。父爱创伤正是导致这些不安全依恋形式的原因之一。
Now, according to attachment theory, people who grew up with supportive and present caregivers are more likely to develop a secure attachment style. That's about 65% of us are causing, according to recent estimates. By contrast, those with less engaged caregivers, possibly people who have a father wound, we are more likely to develop an insecure attachment style, such as an avoidant or an anxious attachment style. A father wound can contribute to these forms of insecure attachment.
它名副其实。它是一种情感印记，一道伤疤，心理上的伤疤，由可能给我们带来痛苦、情绪不适和苦恼的经历所留下，即使我们直到很久以后才意识到，某种损害已经造成。因此，当你走进世界，想要与并非你照顾者的人建立依恋关系时，你所拥有的唯一参照基础就是你与父母之间的依恋关系。
And it is what it sounds like. It is an emotional mark, A scar, a psychological scar, left from an experience that maybe caused us pain, some emotional discomfort and distress, even if we didn't realize it until much later on, some kind of damage was done. And so when you go out into the world and want to form attachments with people who are not your caregivers, the only basis you have for what that should look like is the attachment you have with your parents.
他们是我们人际关系的榜样。而当我们谈论父爱创伤时，他们就是我们与男性建立关系的榜样。你知道，弗洛伊德和荣格经常讨论这一点，过去式，经常讨论过这一点。但我们确实是将与父母的关系作为我们与同性或异性成年人关系的蓝图。我知道这听起来很奇怪，但实际上作为孩子，我们通过观察和经验来学习。我们学会模仿作为孩子时与异性或同性成员的经历，
They are our role model for relationships. And when we're talking about father wounds, they are our role model for relationships with men. You know, Freud and Jung talk about this a lot, talked about this a lot, sorry, past tense. But we really do use our parental relationships as a blueprint for our adult relationships with the same or the opposite gender. I know this sounds quite strange, but really as children, we learn through observation and we learn through experience. And we learn to mimic what we experienced as children with, you know, a member of the opposite sex or the same sex. normally our mother or our father, and we take that through our lives. Our fathers are our first example of what we think men are like, how they behave, how they treat us, their innate character
通常是我们的母亲或父亲，并将其带入我们的生活。我们的父亲是我们对男性的第一印象，包括他们是什么样的人、他们如何行事、他们如何对待我们、他们天生的性格与品质。如果你有一个愤怒的父亲，你就会认为所有男人都是愤怒的。如果你有一个缺席的父亲，你自然会得出结论：所有男人都有一种天生的倾向，会离开你、抛弃你，除非他们试图赢得你的赞许或道歉，否则不会给你关爱和关注。如果你有一个抛弃家庭、出轨、组建新家庭的父亲，你就会认为这是男性命运中不可或缺的一部分，因为你没有任何其他例子可以作为依据。至少没有其他例子对你来说是那么清晰、明显且如此私人的。这就是父亲的角色。这就是父亲的原型，由你的父母设定的原型，因此也就是男性的原型，对吧？你不知道。
and qualities. If you have an angry father, you will think that all men are angry. If you had an absent father, you naturally conclude that all men have this innate tendency to leave and abandon you, to not give you affection or attention unless they're trying to win your approval or apologize. If you had a father who left the family, who cheated, who started a new family, you assume that this is inbuilt to male destiny because you don't have any other examples to base it off. At least no other examples that are that clear and obvious to you that are that kind of personal. And this is kind of the father's role. This is the father archetype, the one that is set by your parent and therefore the male archetype, right? You don't know.
去期待不同的结果。你一无所知，即使你的生活中还有其他男性存在。父亲，你的父亲是你最崇拜的人。因此，由破坏性的互动或关系留下的那道伤疤，开始超越你的思想，延伸到你如何对待男性，你如何与男性建立关系，你如何对待自己，甚至只是你如何对待所有人。它与母亲创伤的主要区别在于母亲和父亲通常扮演的角色不同。主要的区别确实归结于社会期望。这些期望可能并不正确或理想，
to expect differently. You don't know anything else, even if you had other males present in your life. The father, your father is the one you look up to the most. And so that wound that is left from a damaging interaction or relationship begins to expand beyond just your thoughts into how you treat men, into how you engage in relationships with men, into how you treat yourself, but also just people in general. It differs from the mother wound primarily just in the role that a mother typically plays versus the father. The major distinction does really come down to societal expectations. These expectations might not be correct or ideal,
但性别角色仍然决定了父亲被要求提供什么，母亲被要求提供什么，母亲为孩子提供很多情感上的安全感、大量的照顾、安慰、温暖的话语，而父亲通常被视为物质上的提供者或保护者、提供建议的人，也是经济上的提供者。他们通常被视为更严厉或更具纪律性。这并不意味着情况总是如此。我想说的是，这并不意味着情况本该如此。但通常情况下，当父亲缺席或在情感上、身体上无法陪伴时，你知道，可能正在挣扎于他们自己的事情中，
but gender roles do still dictate what fathers are asked to provide compared to mothers, whereby mothers provide a lot of emotional safety for their children, a lot of the care, the comfort, the kind words, whereas fathers are typically seen as physical providers or protectors, advice givers, financial providers as well. they're often seen as more tough or disciplinary. It doesn't mean that that is always the case. I want to say that, it doesn't mean that it should be the case. But often, when a father is absent or emotionally, physically unavailable, you know, maybe struggling with their own things,
因为离婚等原因而疏远，我们仍然可以向母亲寻求情感上的安慰，因为那是我们通常会寻求的人。这并不意味着我们仍然不需要父亲的赞许。我们仍然想要这个人物在我们的生活中提供的支持。如果你从小就觉得不受父亲的爱、不被了解、不被需要，这真的会影响你如何看待自己，因为这些事情中的很多都发生在我们真正形成性格的情感阶段，也就是我们正在发展自尊和自我概念等事物的时期。父亲的缺席会让你觉得是自己出了问题，让你觉得你做了什么事才导致他不爱你。因此，当你长大后，你不断地将男人视为那些
distant because of a divorce, whatnot, we can still go to our mother for emotional comfort because that is who we would normally seek out. It doesn't mean that we don't still want the approval of our father. We still want the support this figure offers in our lives. If you felt unloved, unknown, unwanted by your father from an early age, this really influences how you see yourself because a lot of these things happen during a really formative emotional chapter for us when we are developing things like our self-esteem and our self-concept. And father absenteeism makes you think that something is wrong with you, makes you think that you have done something that has made him not love you. And so as you grow up, you're constantly seeing men as these people who
伤害你的人，但同时也去寻求男性的赞许，以此作为一种方式，几乎是为了掌控过去的痛苦，或者向自己证明历史不会重演。你没有任何其他的指南。你没有其他任何信息源在告诉你采取不同的行动。实际上，我认为我们应该停下来讨论一下，因为我觉得我们需要厘清这些创伤的确切行为或关系根源。以及我们可能会看到的作为这种无序关系症状的全套行为表现。我认为这是一种拔河比赛，一方面渴望父亲的赞许和陪伴，另一方面又
hurt you, but also seeking out the approval of men as a way to almost gain mastery over past pain, or to show yourself that history will not be repeated. You don't have any other guide. You don't have any other source of information that is telling you to act differently. Actually, I think we should stop and talk about that for a second, because I feel like we need to lay down the exact behavioral or relational origins of these kinds of wounds. And the full span of behaviors that we might see is symptomatic of this kind of disorganized relationship. I think it is this tug of war between wanting your father's approval and presence and
抗拒对他的依赖，或者抗拒对他的期望超过他所能提供的，不想对她感到失望，因此不想对其他男性感到失望。正如我们之前所说，我们的父爱创伤是距离、期望破裂的结果（你知道，你的父亲无法提供他应该提供的东西）。而我们希望他提供的，你知道，它通常与身体或情感上缺席、过度保护、控制欲强、有药物滥用问题、在语言、身体和情感上受到虐待的父亲有关。也许他们在你还是个孩子的时候就去世了，尽管这令人悲伤。
pushing away the desire to be reliant on him or to expect more than what he can offer, not wanting to be disappointed in him, therefore not wanting to be disappointed in other men. Our father wounds, as we said before, are the result of a distance, a breach and expectations, you know, your father being unable to provide what he should. And what we want him to provide, you know, it commonly relates to fathers who were physically or emotionally absent, overprotective, controlling, dealing with substance issues, verbally, physically, emotionally abusive. Perhaps they even passed away when you're a child, as sad as it is.
我想对此加个前提，有些事情可能会发生，但未必会导致我们与父爱创伤联系在一起的典型结果。我有一些朋友，他们的父亲不幸去世了，或者入狱了，或者再婚了，他们并没有像其他人那样经历相同的挣扎。另一方面，我也见过一些人，他们拥有两位充满爱心的父母，却依然在维系某些关系和对自我感到安全方面苦苦挣扎。创伤是许多因素、倾向、环境和个性的累积。我认为很多人认为如果发生X，就会发生Y，你知道，如果你的父亲抛弃了你，
And I want to caveat this by saying there are some things that it can, you know, some of these things can occur and not necessarily result in the typical outcomes we associate with father wounds. I have friends whose fathers unfortunately passed away or who went to prison or who have remarried and they have not had the same struggles as other people have had. On the other hand, I have seen people who have had two loving parents who have gone on to really struggle with maintaining certain relationships and feeling secure about themselves. Trauma is accumulation of a lot of factors and predispositions and environments and personality. I think a lot of people view it as if X happens, Y occurs, you know, if your father abandoned you,
你受到了创伤。事情并不总是那样发展。然而，当我们观察到父爱创伤发生时的表现时，情况是这样的。所以我在这里列举几个典型反应模式的例子。首先，那些受到与父亲的关系负面影响的人，可能会倾向于通过推开他人来重复他们情感缺席父母的模式，建立极其死板的边界，进行自我隔离，因为他们害怕不可靠的人，比如那些复制或表现得像他们父亲的人，
you are traumatized. It doesn't always work out that way. What we do observe about father wounds when they occur, though, is this. So I'm going to list a couple examples here of typical patterns that we would see in response. Firstly, people who have been negatively impacted by this relationship with their father might tend to repeat the pattern of their emotionally absent parent by pushing people away, by having incredibly rigid boundaries, self-isolating because they are afraid of unreliable people, such as someone who replicates or appears like their father,
偷偷溜进他们的生活并伤害他们。这意味着你可能很难与人建立联系。你真正亲密的关系会更少。但正如一篇文章所说，一位治疗师说得非常好：“有时，感到孤独的痛苦，与你预期的某人像你父亲那样让你失望的痛苦相比，根本算不了什么。”这就是我们所说的遗弃恐惧。在这些情况下这非常普遍。
sneaking into their life through the cracks and hurting them. That might mean that you struggle connecting with people. You have fewer really close relationships. But as one article put it, this one therapist said it really well, the pain of feeling lonely, sometimes, to you is nothing compared to the pain you anticipate from someone letting you down the way your father did. Now this is what we call an abandonment fear. And it's really common in these situations.
被辜负令人痛苦。被父母之中的任何一人拒绝都令人痛苦。因此，通过避免与任何人亲密接触，我们避免了重复那种与大量可怕的心理、精神、情感痛苦联系在一起的结果。在硬币的另一面，由于我们根据照顾者的行为形成了应该如何被对待的理解，我们也可能习惯了来自父亲的情感不可用或糟糕的对待。因此，当这些事情可能出现在我们的成年恋爱关系中时，我们已经对它们有了耐受力。
Being let down hurts. Being rejected by a parent of all people hurts. And so by avoiding getting close to anyone, we avoid repeating that outcome that we associate with a lot of terrible psychological, mental, emotional pain. On the other side of the coin, because we develop an understanding of how we should be treated based on our caregiver's behavior, we may be also used to emotionally unavailable or poor treatment from our fathers. And so when these things maybe appear in our adult romantic relationships, we already have a tolerance for them. we have been taught that they are acceptable. So you're not pushing people away,
我们被教导它们是可以接受的。所以你不是在推开别人，我不想说你是让别人进来，因为这听起来好像是你的错，但有些人可能会进入你的生活，他们可能没有以正确或尊重的方式对待你，他们是操纵性的、情感上缺席的、精神虐待的，这会让你想起你的父亲。在另一条轨道上，我们也可能维持着情感空洞或肤浅的关系、伴侣关系。
but you'll, I don't want to say letting people in because it makes it sound like you're at fault here, but people are entering your life who might not treat you right or with respect, who are manipulative, emotionally absent, mentally abusive, who remind you of your father. In another lane, me may also sustain a pattern of emotionally hollow or shallow relationships, situationships.
为什么会这样？嗯，一些心理治疗师会建议，你可能有一种无意识的愿望，想要通过与一个能创造你在童年时期经历过的类似感觉和熟悉感觉的人建立关系，来修复早期的父爱创伤。所以基本上你所寻找的是父亲类型的替代品，有时是一个年长的人，有时是一个复制了他相同的精神、身体、精神模式的人。因为通过这样做，你所经历的是可以预测的事情。你已经知道了结果，因为你对这种类型的男人很熟悉。但你和这些人约会得越多，你就越觉得自己可以改变他们。通过改变你在浪漫关系中与这个人的关系，感觉你对与父亲的关系有了更多的控制权。
And why is that? Well, some psychotherapist would suggest that you may have an unconscious wish to repair the early father wound by having a relationship with a person that creates similar feelings and familiar feelings that you experienced from your childhood. So basically what you are seeking out is a father type replacement, sometimes someone who is older, sometimes someone who replicates his same emotional, physical, mental patterns. because by doing that, what you're experiencing is something that is predictable. You already know the outcome because you're familiar with this kind of man. But the more you date these people, the more you feel like you can change them. And by changing the relationship you have with this person romantically, it feels like you have more power over the relationship you have with your father.
因为通过控制当前的局面，它让你觉得你本可以控制过去的局面。现在，与一个始终如一、靠谱的人建立关系实际上可能会让人感到在情感上具有很大的威胁性，因为我们不习惯那样。因此，即使对我们更糟糕，即使这个人控制欲强、缺席或要求苛刻，我们也倾向于回到我们已经习惯的状态。这可能也源于自尊心和自信心的低下，这是一种因父亲让你觉得自己不配拥有、让你觉得自己不配得到爱而表现出来的结果。
Because by controlling this current situation, it makes you feel like you could have had control over the past situation. Now, being in a relationship with someone consistent and reliable can actually feel potentially very emotionally threatening because we're not used to that. And so we tend to return to what we have become accustomed to even if it's worse for us, even if the person is controlling or absent or demanding. This may also evolve from a place of poor self-esteem and self-confidence that manifests as a result of a father who made you feel undeserving and made you feel undeserving and made you feel
从照顾者、父亲、我们的父母那里获得爱和接受，对于培养我们的自我价值感和自我概念非常重要，因为他们对我们说的话成为了我们的真理，并教会了我们如何对待自己。所以有人前几天对我说这个，真的戳中了要害。我们每个人的大脑、思维中都有一个内在的批判者，在对我们说负面的话。那个内在的批判者听起来像你的母亲还是你的父亲？我认为这非常能说明你可能有什么样的创伤。或者它听起来可能完全是另一个人，但当我们谈论父爱创伤时，通常你听到自己对自己说的话，听起来很像你父亲
unlovable. Receiving love and acceptance from a caregiver, from a father, from our parents in general is so important for developing our sense of self-worth and self-concept because the words they speak to us become our truth and they teach us how to treat ourselves. So someone said this to me the other day and it really like hit the nail on the head. Each of us has an inner critic in our brain, in our mind, saying negative things to us. Does that inner critic sound like your mother or your father? I think that's really revealing of what kind of wound you might have. Or it might sound like someone else entirely, but when we're talking about father wounds, often the words that you hear yourself say to yourself sound a lot like the words that your father
小时候对你说的话。它可能会告诉我们，我们不配得到爱。这就是为什么我们的父亲缺席。我们很容易被取代。这就是为什么我们的父亲离开。我们很坏。这就是为什么我们的父亲对我们吼叫。我们很笨。这就是为什么我们的父亲批评我们。你可能会通过极力表现得好、倾向于完美主义、做一个好孩子来对抗这一点，但却发现没有任何成就、没有任何积极的肯定能让你觉得自己足够好或有价值，因为这些消极的信念在你心中根深蒂固。有时，拥有另一个父母，大声反对这些事情或用积极的态度对抗这种消极情绪，会具有很好的保护作用，但是，你知道，有时
spoke to you as a child. It might tell us that we aren't worthy of love. That's why our father was absent. We are easily replaceable. That's why our father left. We are bad. That's why our father yelled at us. We are stupid. That's why our father criticized us. You might counteract this by trying really hard to be good, leaning on perfectionism, and being the good kid, but still finding that nothing, no achievement, no positive affirmation, makes you feel good enough or worthy because these negative beliefs are so deeply ingrained in you. Sometimes having another parent who speaks out against these things or fights back against this negativity with positivity can be really protective, but, you know, there are just times
那个内在的批判者比我们的外部啦啦队声音更大。因此，我们仍然渴望父亲的赞许。那是我们渴望的，因为我们从未得到过它。特别是对于那些拥有疏离、缺席、情感上不可企及的父亲的男孩来说，这其实有一个特定的名字。它被称为“父饥饿”，即无论他们受到怎样的对待和伤害，他们在心理上的某个层面上仍然渴望父亲的赞许和陪伴。
when that inner critic is louder than our external cheerleader. And so we still want our father's approval. That is what we crave because we never got it. In men, especially, who have a distant, absent, emotionally unavailable father, there is actually a specific name for this. It's known as Father Hunger, whereby, regardless of how they were treated and hurt, they still psychologically on some level, hunger after their father's approval and presence.
或者他们在老师、导师、老板身上寻找男性榜样、男性人物，作为父亲剥夺了他们的爱、支持和鼓励的替代品或代理人。我的父亲从未爱过我，但这里有这样一个人会爱。这里有一个男性人物可以替代他，可以给予我一直以来从他那里寻找的所有东西。我真的认为我们需要对此进行更多的研究，主要是针对小男孩和男性，最好也是纵向研究，因为从逻辑上讲，这确实很有道理，对吧？
or they seek out male role models, male figures, in teachers, mentors, bosses as a replacement or a proxy for the love and support and encouragement their father deprived them of. My father never loved me, but here is this person who will. Here is this male figure who can be his replacement, who can give me all the things that I was always looking to him for. I really think that we need to do more research on this, primarily with young boys and men, hopefully longitudinally as well because I think logically this does make a lot of sense, right?
就像男孩崇拜并渴望成为他们的父亲一样，女性会继承母亲的特质。但我真的很想探究这种对外部偶像的依恋从何而来，他们是如何选择替代品的。父爱创伤的另一种表征模式是，人们发现自己像父亲一样大发雷霆。或者他们被愤怒和怨恨压得喘不过气来。以至于无法控制自己的情绪爆发。这可能也是因为他们没有被展示如何进行自我调节、如何自我抚慰的榜样。有句老话说，如果你在一个家里有愤怒男人的环境中长大，
Like boys admire and aspire to be their fathers, women take on the traits of their mothers. But I really want to look into where this attachment to an external icon comes from, how they choose the replacement. Another kind of pattern that is indicative of a father wound is that people find themselves lashing out as their fathers did. Or they are so overwhelmed with rage and resentment. that they can't control their emotional outbursts. It may also be because they have not been shown an example of how to self-regulate, how to self-soothe. There is this saying that if you grew up with an angry man in your house,
你家里就会一直有一个愤怒的男人。因为你承接了那种愤怒。你变成了那个愤怒的男人。你别无他法。如果你的父亲可以愤怒，通过为自己夺回这种愤怒，并向世界、向他人明显地表现出愤怒，你会觉得自己不再是靶子，你是所有曾经针对你的狂怒的
there will always be an angry man in your house. Because you take on that rage. You become the angry man. You don't know any other way. And if your father got to be angry, by reclaiming that anger for yourself and being visibly angry at the world, at others, you feel like you are no longer the target, you were the distributor of all the fury
分发者。这把从未感到的力量还给了你。或者它也只是一种试图通过功能失调的应对机制寻找宣泄口的未解决创伤。悲伤、痛苦、挫折无处可去。它积聚起来，让你感觉糟糕透顶。而摆脱困境的方法就是愤怒。我们通常可以把这追溯到父爱创伤。最后，在一个相似的层面上，我们有冲动行为。你想要掌控自己的生活，用一种你可能无法与控制欲强甚至虐待狂父亲抗衡的方式。所以你大发脾气，因为它给了你一种自由的错觉。
that was once directed towards you. And so it gives you back the power you never felt you had. Or it also is just this unresolved trauma trying to find an outlet through a dysfunctional coping mechanism. The sadness, the pain, the frustration has nowhere to go. And it builds up, it makes you feel terrible. And the way out of that is to be angry. And we can often trace that back to a father wound. And finally, kind of on a similar note, we have impulsive behaviors. You want to gain control over your life in a way that you may have been unable to do with a controlling or even an abusive father. And so you act out because it gives you the illusion of freedom.
你做你爸爸说不准做的一切。因为那是强化内心的成年版本的你的一种方式，即他不再对你这个成年版本拥有控制权。你不再是个孩子了。那个童年版本的你已经消失了。现在由你做主。因此，几乎作为一种迟来的叛逆，你可能会做一些非常具有自我毁灭性的事情，或者进行自我破坏，因为至少你现在有发言权了。
You do everything your dad said not to do. Because that is one way to reinforce within yourself that he no longer has control over this adult version of you. You are no longer a child. That child version of you is gone. You are in charge now. And so almost as a delayed rebellion, you may do things that are quite self-destructive or engage in self-sabotage because at least you now have a say.
即使你的行为与你想要的并不一致，你也得以掌控全局。我想这就是那些父亲缺席的人有很多性行为的刻板印象的来源。我只想说我查阅过这方面的资料。我搜索过。我研究过。我深入挖掘过。我没有找到任何一篇经过同行评审的学术文章可以为我证实那种刻板印象。
Even if your actions aren't aligning with what you want, you get to be in control. I think this is where the stereotype of people with absent fathers having a lot of sex comes from. I just want to say I looked into this. I searched. I researched. I deep dived. I did not find a single peer-reviewed academic article that could confirm that stereotype for me.
所以我想我们可以把它忽略掉。父爱创伤可能会导致更多冒险行为，但这并不总是与性有关，对吧？如果我们愿意的话，我们也可以对入店行窃或危险驾驶做出同样等同的联系。不过，就生活结果而言，有一些学术研究观察到，在没有父亲陪伴下长大的孩子更有可能辍学，更有可能在监狱里度过时光。不过，这是在美国进行的研究。我认为考虑代际创伤、系统性种族主义、社会支持不足等因素也很重要。我认为这些因素既导致了父亲的缺席，
So I think we can kind of disregard it. Father wounds may result in more risk-taking behavior, but that is not always related to sex, right? We could make the same and equal link to shoplifting if we wanted or dangerous driving. In terms of life outcomes, though, there has been some research, academic research, that has observed how children who grew up without a present father are more likely to drop out school, more likely to spend time in jail. This was research conducted in the United States, though. I do think it's important to also consider things like intergenerational trauma, systemic racism, poor social supports. I think that contributes both to father absenteeism
也导致了童年和成年的结果。所以我想，每当我们看到类似的文章说，如果这个人有这个，他们就会变成这样。我们必须坐下来真正仔细审查一下，因为它并不总是那么一刀切。我们还看到了一项研究，实际上是来自澳大利亚的这篇论文表明，童年时期父亲的缺席会对我们的社会情感发展产生负面影响，特别是通过增加攻击性或寻求关注的行为。这是我们已经从上面收集到的东西，对吧？你拥有所有针对你的狂怒，而你从未学会如何自我调节，因为你的父亲从未自我调节过。你对这个拥有巨大权力、你一直渴望得到其赞许的男人有一种感觉，现在你已经是成年人了，你从未得到过那些，现在你已经是成年人了，你仍然在寻找它，你做所有这些事情作为一种方式，也许是为了获得关注，但也为了带回对生活的自由感和控制感。这既有趣，但我要说的是，看到这段关系是多么重要以及当它受到干扰时会发生什么，更令人震惊。再次说明，
and also childhood outcomes and adulthood outcomes. So I think when anytime we see like an article like that that's saying like, if this person has this, they will become this. We got to sit back and really examine that a little bit because it's not always as clear cut as that. We're also seeing research, this paper actually out of Australia that suggests that absent fathers during childhood can negatively impact our social emotional development, particularly by increasing aggressive or attention seeking behaviors. That is something that we have already gathered from above, right? You have all this fury that was directed towards you that you never learned how to self-regulate because your father never self-regulated. And you have all this sense of like this person,
情况并非总是如此，但在一个非常无意识的层面上，我认为我们有着对爱和依恋那些本该照顾我们的人的深切需求。如果他们没有证明自己能够满足这个需求，如果他们获得了我们的信任却又打破了它，
man that has all this power over you that you always wanted approval from and now that you're an adult and you never got that now that you're an adult and you're still looking for it you do all these things as a way to maybe gain attention but also to bring back a sense of freedom and control over your life it's both interesting but i would say more so devastating to see how important this relationship is and what occurs when it is disturbed once again i will say it It's not always the case, but on a very unconscious level, I think we have a deep need to feel love and attach to the people who are meant to care for us. And if they don't prove that they can meet this need, if they gain our trust and then break it,
如果他们伤害了我们，其影响是深远而重大的，并以许多方式表现出来。母亲、父亲、父母、照顾者，人类依恋和依赖他人的需求也许是我们最原始的需求之一。天哪，当有人不认真对待这种责任时，有时我们就是没有力量去原谅他们。所以接下来我想谈谈，我们该怎么办？如果你在自己身上认出了父爱创伤，你难道就这么带着它生活吗？你难道就带着失败的关系生活吗？你难道就带着愤怒生活吗？你难道只是日复一日地试着忽视它吗？还是有什么我们可以做的事情？嗯，我想我当然不会这么说如果没有的话，我不喜欢虚假的希望，而是关于治愈和爱的希望。
if they harm us, the impacts of that are deep and significant and show up in so many ways. Mother, father, parent, caregiver, the human needs to bond and rely on others is perhaps one of our most primal. And God forbid, when someone doesn't take that responsibility seriously, sometimes we just don't have it in us to forgive them. So what I want to talk about next is, what do we do? If you have recognized a father wound within yourself, do you just live with it? Do you just live with the failed relationships? Do you just live with the anger? Do you just try and ignore it day in and day out? Or is there something that we can do? Well, I think of course I wouldn't be saying that if there wasn't, I do not like the idea of false hope, but one of healing and love.
如果他们伤害了我们，其影响将是深远且重大的，并以多种方式显现出来。母亲、父亲、父母、照顾者，人类去建立纽带并依赖他人的需求也许是我们最原始的本能之一。天哪，当有人不认真对待这种责任时，有时我们就是无法原谅他们。所以接下来我想谈谈，我们该怎么办？如果你在自己身上意识到了父系创伤，难道就只能带着它生活吗？难道只能接受失败的感情吗？难道只能带着愤怒生活吗？难道只能日复一日地试着去忽视它吗？还是说我们可以做些什么？嗯，我想当然，如果什么都做不了，我是不会这么说的，我不喜欢虚假希望的概念，但我相信治愈与爱。
So we're going to talk about that a little bit more, the steps forward, the steps out of this after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
所以我们在稍作休息后会更多地讨论这个问题，即前进的步伐，摆脱困境的步伐。2%。这是指在也有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了心理坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养应变能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越健康产业中那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上是促进炎症的。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。这就是 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的“2%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯
double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
其中包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·Hill 滔滔不绝地谈论 80 年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84 年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以谈论快克，只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以。谢谢你把话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark,
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克，
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却仍然在追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于胜利和失败。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯，
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. a good person. Join me,
因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同信任水平。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。一个好人。加入我，
Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
基尔·盖恩斯，我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio app。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones.
发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭斗争以证明真相。你串改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我串改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Naranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这花了一支互联网侦探大军才破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋，迈克尔·纳兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没结束。在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。
If you have identified a father wound within yourself, that is, impacting your ability to love, to form connections with the kind of person you want in your life for the long haul, to form a secure attachment, to date, to manage your emotions, to see yourself accurately and with compassion, the next question is naturally, well, what do I do? There are so few guidebooks for this kind of stuff. And a lot of the resources focus specifically on trying to repair the relationship. I think that's admirable. I do think that's part of the story, but that's not always
如果你在自己身上发现了父爱创伤，也就是说，它影响了你爱人、与你生活中长期期望的那种人建立联系的能力、形成安全依恋、约会、管理你的情绪、准确且富有同情心地看待自己的能力，那么接下来的问题自然是，好吧，我该怎么办？这类事情的指南太少了。而且很多资源都专门集中在试图修复关系上。我认为这值得称赞。我确实认为这是故事的一部分，但这并不总是
an option for all of us. I think the reason we see this perspective of forgiveness more than others is because if you do any research into father wounds, you will find that a lot of the literature on father wounds has very religious undertones that are perhaps preaching something that is outdated, not good for everyone, but matches the internal teachings of a specific faith or a church. I see a lot about how not having a biological father should mean you accept your spiritual father or how forgiveness is the only path forward because that is what God preached. Spiritual healing can be powerful, but let's be honest, it's not for everyone. It hasn't really
我们所有人的选择。我认为我们看到这种原谅的视角多于其他视角的原因是，如果你对父爱创伤做任何研究，你会发现很多关于父爱创伤的文献都有非常浓厚的宗教基调，这些基调可能宣扬一些过时的、对每个人都不好的东西，但符合特定信仰或教堂的内部教义。我看到很多关于没有亲生父亲应该意味着你接受你的精神父亲，或者原谅是唯一的出路，因为那是上帝宣扬的。精神疗愈可以很强大，但老实说，它并不适合每个人。它并没有真正
played a role in my life. There is also a power dynamic there of submission and at times sweeping things under the rug that I don't love that is not therapeutic. And that can be really confusing and frustrating, very hard to square. When you're looking for help, you're going online, out into the world, being like, okay, I've done the work. I've identified what has happened. Now I want like a reasonable explanation for what to do next and the only option you have is forgiveness. I just don't think that that is particularly fair. It's not an option for everyone, not just practically because you may not have a relationship with your father anymore. They may have passed on, they may have experienced a significant cognitive decline since the last time you saw them,
在我的生活中发挥作用。那里也存在着服从的权力动态，有时甚至会把事情扫到地毯下面掩盖起来，我不喜欢这样，那不是治疗性的。这可能会非常令人困惑和沮丧，很难调和。当你寻找帮助时，你上网，走向世界，心想，好吧，我已经做了功课。我已经确定了发生了什么。现在我想要一个关于接下来该怎么做的合理解释，而你唯一的选择就是原谅。我只是觉得这并不是特别公平。这并不是每个人的选择，不仅在实际层面上是因为你可能不再与父亲有联系。他们可能已经去世了，自你上次见到他们以来，他们可能经历了严重的认知衰退，
you may just, like I said, not have any contact with them. So practically forgiveness, active forgiveness is not an option, but emotionally and mentally it might not be an option either. We just don't want to forgive and have to go through the process that would allow us to find closure. I do think that there is such a thing as forgiving someone for yourself and not for them. that is a really powerful thing and can be incredibly healing for some people to be like, I understand why this happened and I understand that it wasn't my fault and I forgive you for what you may have done. But also I think you, in order to forgive sometimes, it does have to be this active remembering
你可能就像我说的，与他们没有任何联系。所以在实际层面上，原谅，主动原谅并不是一个选择，但在情感和心理层面上它可能也不是一个选择。我们只是不想原谅，也不想经历那个能让我们找到心理闭环的过程。我确实认为存在着为了自己而不是为了别人而原谅某人这回事。这是一件非常强大的事情，对某些人来说可以具有令人难以置信的疗愈作用，比如，我理解为什么会发生这一切，我也理解这不是我的错，我原谅你可能做过的事。但同时我也认为，为了原谅，有时必须进行这种主动的回忆，
and that can really open the door to be hurt again. You are not always going to be promised an answer that will satisfy you, especially since people don't like to be confronted with their flaws and their wrongdoing. And these wounds are often very intergenerational. You may also risk being back into an unstable, unhealthy relationship which may trigger past coping mechanisms and trauma. There are many reasons why people don't necessarily want to forgive. Family trauma is not a situation where you always have to forgive either, but it doesn't mean that you are cursed to kind of struggle for the rest of your life. I think that you can acknowledge why your father was like this, what made
而这确实会为再次受伤打开大门。你并不总是能得到一个能让你满意的答案，特别是人们不喜欢面对自己的缺点和做错的事。而这些伤口通常是跨代传的。你还可能冒着重新陷入不稳定、不健康关系的风险，这可能会引发过去的应对机制和创伤。人们不一定想原谅有很多原因。家庭创伤也不是一种你总是必须原谅的情况，但这并不意味着你注定要在余生中苦苦挣扎。我认为你可以承认为什么你的父亲会是这样，是什么造就了
him this absent figure, what made him this angry man in the house, what made him emotionally unavailable or harsh or mean, and still reach the conclusion that what is best for you is to remain distanced. That is how you will move forward. I really do believe that we cannot always rely on other people to heal us, especially the person who has created the pain and the emotional psychological damage to begin with. They can provide us with information. They can provide us with information. They can apologize, they can provide us with explanations, but I do think we have to take all of that and reach our own conclusion. This may involve really unpacking your attachment style, or when you are tempted to fall into patterns of avoidance, isolation, anger, self-sabotage,
他这个缺席的人物，是什么让他在家里成了这样一个愤怒的男人，是什么让他情感上不可及、严厉或刻薄，并且仍然得出结论：对你最好的做法是保持距离。这就是你前进的方式。我真的相信我们不能总是依赖别人来治愈我们，特别是那个从一开始就造成痛苦和情感心理损害的人。他们可以为我们提供信息。他们可以为我们提供信息。他们可以道歉，他们可以为我们提供解释，但我确实认为我们必须吸收所有这些并得出我们自己的结论。这可能涉及真正剖析你的依恋风格，或者当你试图陷入回避、孤立、愤怒、自我破坏、
pain. Are you seeing those things in your relationships, especially, especially your relationships with men. And as a coping mechanism, which is what these things are, is it actually serving you? Is it making your life better to push people away? Is it making your life better to keep going for people who are emotionally unavailable so that you can keep them in a distance? It might make you feel emotionally safer
痛苦的模式时。你是否在你的关系中看到了这些情况，特别是，特别是你与男人的关系。作为一个应对机制，这些事情就是这样，它真的对你有用吗？把人们推开会让你的生活变得更好吗？不断寻找那些情感上不可及的人以便能与他们保持距离，会让你的生活变得更好吗？这可能会让你在情感上感到更安全，
because it minimizes the capacity to be hurt again. But in the long run, I just don't feel like we have to live in this state of always being hypervigilant to the potential for hurt. Part of that involves allowing people in taking a chance on your ability to trust someone else, even though you know that they could potentially hurt you. Now, this is, I was going to talk about this a little bit more, but we actually have an whole episode on this called Understanding Our Fear of Intimacy. and there's just a lot more advice in there that I feel like I would just be repeating.
因为它最大限度地减少了再次受伤的可能性。但从长远来看，我只是觉得我们不必生活在这种总是对潜在伤害保持高度警惕的状态中。其中一部分包括允许别人走进来，冒险去相信你能够信任别人的能力，即使你知道他们有可能伤害你。现在，这个，我本来想多谈谈这个，但我们实际上有一整集关于这个的节目叫做“理解我们对亲密关系的恐惧”。那里有更多我觉得自己只会重复的建议。
So if you want more information on that, go and listen to that episode. It talks about how to push past fear and relationships, how to unpack fear, how to unpack the wounds, i.e. father wounds that contribute to anxiety and stress and repetition in our relationship patterns. The thing about these kinds of wounds like father wounds is that they do often become generational, right? They do often get passed down. and not just generation, but they do become repeated and very ingrained. And it impacts the people around us, but most of all, it impacts our own happiness and our own fulfillment and our sense of peace.
所以如果你想了解更多关于这方面的信息，去听那一集吧。它讨论了如何在关系中克服恐惧，如何剖析恐惧，如何剖析导致我们关系模式中的焦虑、压力和重复的伤口，即父爱创伤。关于这种伤口，比如父爱创伤，它们通常会变成代际的，对吧？它们确实经常被传下来。不仅是代际，而且它们变得重复且根深蒂固。它影响着我们周围的人，但最重要的是，它影响着我们自己的幸福、我们的成就感和我们的平静感。
That is who matters the most in the situation. You, you matter the most. And I think there is a lot of power in how we choose to speak to ourselves to get rid of that angry or disappointing voice in our head, to release our own sense of blame and shame that seems to linger, even after we've moved out, even after we have no contact with our father. And that is where the practice of reparenting also becomes so critical. You may have heard about inner child healing or in a teen healing recently. We've talked about it before on the podcast.
这才是这种情况中最重要的。你，你才是最重要的。我认为我们在选择如何与自己对话以摆脱脑海中那个愤怒或失望的声音、释放那些似乎挥之不去的自责和羞耻感方面拥有很大的力量，即使在我们搬出去之后，即使在我们与父亲没有联系之后。这也是育儿式自我疗愈（reparenting）变得如此关键的地方。你最近可能听说过内在小孩疗愈或内在青少年疗愈。我们以前在播客中讨论过它。
I think it is a real amazing way of thinking about childhood problems as having adult solutions, right? is there is something that you can do about them, even if you're no longer in that situation. So basically the premise of this kind of healing is that our childhood self does not disappear. The memories that we make at that time remain. They are a foundation for all of our future experiences, for our interpretations, for how we see the world. And there are things that are stored in those past versions of ourselves that impact us in the current day. obviously we cannot go back and undo the past as sad as it is there is nothing we can say
我认为这是一种非常棒的方式，将童年问题视为拥有成年人的解决方案，对吧？就是有一些事情你可以对它们采取行动，即使你不再处于那种情况中。所以基本上这种疗愈的前提是，我们童年时的自我并没有消失。我们在那个时期建立的记忆依然存在。它们是我们所有未来经历、我们的解释以及我们如何看世界的基准。在过去的那些自我版本中储存了一些东西，影响着我们今天的生活。显然我们无法回到过去并抹去过去，尽管这很悲伤，但我们没有什么可说的，
nothing we can do that is going to undo those experiences so we think a lot of us feel quite trapped by past trauma right i'm only the things that have happened to me and there is nothing i can do to act on those things because they are untouchable but the idea around inner child healing is that that version of you that was hurt, that was harmed, that was damaged, that was put through psychological, emotional, physical pain, they are still alive, they are still present. And as you become an adult, you have the opportunity to reparent them in a way that is going to be beneficial and healing. You are now responsible for creating a psychological, internal environment where you feel safe enough to explore the past and then heal from that by giving your inner child
没有什么我们可以做的能够抹去那些经历，所以我们很多人对过去的创伤感到相当困陷，对吧？我只是发生在我身上的事情的总和，我对此无能为力，因为它们是不可触碰的。但围绕内在小孩疗愈的想法是，那个曾受伤的、受损的、遭受心理、情感、身体痛苦的那个版本的你，他们依然活着，他们依然在场。随着你成为成年人，你有机会以一种有益和疗愈的方式重新抚育他们。你现在有责任创造一个心理上的内部环境，让你觉得足够安全去探索过去，然后通过给你的内在小孩以
what they never had while simultaneously showing yourself that you can meet your own needs. You are deserving of love or joy or safety or whatever it is that you required that you did not get. You are safe now. The past is the past. That is a terrible thing, but is also a beautiful thing. Because you are now this future current version of you who knows more, who can do more, who can act on your knowledge and heal that version of you that couldn't help themselves. I really love this idea.
他们从未拥有的东西来从中疗愈，同时向自己展示你可以满足自己的需求。你值得拥有爱、快乐、安全，或者你所需要的任何你没有得到的东西。你现在很安全。过去就是过去。这是一件糟糕的事情，但也是一件美丽的事情。因为你现在是这个未来/当下的版本的你，你知道得更多，能做更多，能够根据你的知识采取行动，并疗愈那个无法自救的版本的你。我真的很喜欢这个想法。
Part of inner child healing involves, firstly, like, setting boundaries for yourself, the boundaries that your childhood self couldn't set, creating environments and opportunities for joy and for happiness, giving into your inner child's needs by providing them with the things that they didn't get, whether that is, like, material and physical, like, clothes that they wanted or food that they didn't have, or comforts that they weren't allowed to indulge in.
内在小孩疗愈的一部分首先包括：为自己设定界限，设定你童年时自己无法设定的界限，为快乐和幸福创造环境和机会，通过提供他们没有得到的东西来满足你内在小孩的需求，无论是物质和身体上的，比如他们想要的衣服或他们没有的食物，或者是他们不被允许沉溺的安慰。
And then also just speaking kindly to that version of you. Like I said, there is this inner critic in all of us. And a lot of the time, it sounds either like our mother or our father or someone from our history. We take on that negative voice and it becomes our own. So instead of thinking of it as your father's voice, think of it as your inner child's voice. Of this five-year-old self sitting in front of you saying, I feel stupid. I feel unlovable. I feel undeserving. If a five-year-old was saying that to you, what would you say back to them? You wouldn't be like, oh my God, shut up. I don't want to think that
然后也只是对那个版本的你温柔地说话。就像我说的，我们所有人心中都有这样一个内在批评者。很多时候，它听起来要么像我们的母亲，要么像我们的父亲，要么像我们历史上的某个人。我们接受了那种消极的声音，它成了我们自己的声音。所以，不要把它当作你父亲的声音，把它当作你内在小孩的声音。这个坐在你面前的五岁自己的声音说：我觉得自己很蠢。我觉得自己不可爱。我觉得自己不配。如果一个五岁的孩子对你这么说，你会对他们说什么？你不会说，哦天哪，闭嘴吧。我不想再那样想
anymore. You wouldn't be like, oh yeah, you're totally right. That is who we are. Of course not. That's a five-year-old child. That is a seven-year-old child. That is an infant. And so treat them as if that version of you was sitting in front of you right now saying all those things. How would you speak back to them? How would you ask them to change their thoughts, to be more aligned with how much you love them and the goodness and the vulnerability and the purity that you can see in them. There are so many other examples of this that I think are so valuable. But basically what it comes down to is just radical self-compassion,
了。你不会说，哦是的，你完全正确。那就是我们。当然不会。那是一个五岁的孩子。那是一个七岁的孩子。那是一个婴儿。所以把他们当作那个版本的你现在正坐在你面前说着所有这些话来对待。你会对他们说些什么？你会如何要求他们改变他们的想法，使其更符合你对他们的爱，以及你在他们身上能看到的善良、脆弱和纯洁？还有很多这方面的例子我认为非常有价值。但基本上归结起来就是彻底的自我同情，
choosing to love yourself forcefully almost, even when everything about your past, everything about who you believe you are is telling you that you are undeserving, it is almost an act of rebellion to say, no I'm not going to listen to that. I'm going to set a whole new attitude towards myself. I'm going to set up a whole new perspective, a whole new way of living that is one of joy, that is one of acceptance, that is one of love and openness.
几乎是强迫自己去选择爱自己，即使你过去的每一件事、关于你认为自己是谁的每一件事都在告诉你，你不配，说“不，我不会听那个”几乎是一种叛逆的行为。我要为自己树立一种全新态度。我要建立一个全新的视角，一种全新的生活方式，这是一种充满快乐、接纳、爱和开放的生活方式。
And whatever happened in the past is in the past, I now have a duty to embrace it and move forward. So I think that's where I'm going to end this episode. I want to send complete utter love to any one of you who is dealing with a father wound right now. I really hope that this has helped you understand it more, understand how it does make us who we are, why there are certain things in your life right now that feel out of control because they may not even be in your control.
无论过去发生什么都已经是过去，我现在有责任去拥抱它并继续前行。所以我想这就是我要结束这一集的地方。我想向任何一个现在正在处理父爱创伤的你们发送完全彻底的爱。我真的希望这能帮助你们更好地理解它，理解它是如何造就了现在的我们，为什么你生活中现在有些事情感觉失控，因为它们甚至可能根本不在你的控制之中。
They are subconsciously coming from childhood treatment that you are not aware of yet. I will also say there is so much that a therapist can help with when it comes to this, particularly a psychotherapist. A lot of the stuff that happens in our unconscious just has been kind of described and derived from a lot of Carl Jung's work, and he obviously informed psychotherapy, so there are people out there who are so equipped to help you through this.
它们是潜意识里源自你尚未意识到的童年待遇。我还要说的是，当涉及到这一点时，治疗师可以提供很多帮助，特别是心理治疗师。在我们无意识中发生的大部分事情，其实都是从卡尔·荣格的大量工作2中描述和衍生出来的，他显然为心理治疗提供了基础，所以外面有很多人具备充分的资格来帮助你度过难关。
But I am really sending you love, and I'm sending you healing, and I hope that you learn something. I hope that you understand yourself better now. And if you did enjoy this episode and you feel like there are someone else who needs to hear it, please feel free to send it to them. And make sure you leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. And if you have thoughts, have feelings, want to share,
但我真的在向你们发送爱，向你们发送疗愈，我希望你们学到了一些东西。我希望你们现在能更好地理解自己。如果你喜欢这一集，并且觉得有其他人需要听听，请随时分享给他们。并且务必在 Apple Podcast、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你有想法、有感受、想要分享，
you can send me a message at that psychology podcast. I love hearing from you guys. If you have an episode suggestion, if you want us to dive into Mother Wounds next, maybe that would be a great one to do. Please let me know. And as always, be kind to yourself, be gentle with yourself.
你可以给我发信息 at that psychology podcast。我喜欢听到你们的意见。如果你有剧集建议，如果你想让我们接下来探讨母爱创伤，也许那会是一个很棒的主题。请告诉我。一如既往，善待自己，对自己温柔一点。
And we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the status. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
我们下周将带着另一集回归。2%。这是指在也有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了心理坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养应变能力的科学。
in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。这就是 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
她们将事情掌握在自己手中。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
On the Look Back at it podcast, From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在 Look Back at it 播客中，从 1979 年开始，这对我和说是个大时刻。84 年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·Hill 谈论 80 年代一样。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
84 年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方真正都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在进行这些对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to Learn the Hardway on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an I-Heart podcast Guaranteed Human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你需要这样做，在 iHeartRadio app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一档 iHeart 播客，保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。